more than 12 000 people have served in
Congress since the first Congress sat in
1789 and today voters will choose the
next slate of American leaders the good
news all of us are invited to be a part
of it
[Music]
it happens in more places than you can
imagine schools and community centers
but also laundromats and bowling alleys
Old Farm sheds and lifeguard stands
Americans vote in tens of thousands of
locations all across this country not
even counting vote by mail and this year
yes this year we may yet set a record
for participation in a midterm but only
if we care enough to do it not because
it's a perfect system not because this
year we have our choice of perfect
candidates but because voting is the
only way we have to change that system
to punish or reward those candidates not
just in Washington by the way but in
your own backyard do you care about
which crimes get prioritized pay
attention to your local race for
attorney general do you think a lot
about what your kids should be learning
you'll want to vote for school board and
what about your money if you have an
opinion about how much of it should go
to the state take a look at your
governor's race but Above All America
and for whatever reason vote not just
for the sticker though the stickers are
pretty cool but because it really does
matter for the country and for you
yeah it really does guys and as we
conclude here two hours of coverage here
on Election Day it's it's a great
reminder that this election everybody
who can hear my voice right now there is
something in it that will affect your
life and if you've got the time today
vote if you don't have the time make it
it really does have consequences
I absolutely agree I remember when I
turned 18 I couldn't wait to vote and
that still hasn't changed thank you Tony
we invite you to stay with CBS news for
a complete coverage of today's voting as
the results come in this evening our
midterm election coverage begins at
eight o'clock Eastern time